this is where you come to the news from
by the way me dude we hit it hard
Toronto Blue Jays dropped pitcher
Anthony Bass
for
anti-lgbtq comments now when you read
that you think okay he hates
gays and trans people but if you're a
little bit smarter you'll be like oh
wait a second the media acts like your
anti-lgbtq if somebody tells you hey I'm
trans and you go oh
they act like because you do that
900 trans people are going to get hit by
a car right like if you're just not
totally like when someone says hey I'm
trans if you don't go give me a t and
have five people behind you T give me an
r r
o trans like if you don't do that you're
perpetuating
genocide you know what I'm saying
like
that's what the media acts like if you
don't literally carry around a [__]
rainbow flag in Los Angeles if you live
here for at least two hours a day during
pride month
you're the reason that trans people are
dying he posted that there should be
boycotts of Target and Bud Light because
Target sells uh sexual underwear for
children which is [__] batshit crazy
to me and then Bud Light uh which I
don't really give a [__] about but they
just have that crazy Dylan Mulvaney
saying
I'm a woman and drink Bud Light which I
don't care about at all because I don't
give a [__] I don't drink beer and also
I don't care that much and it doesn't
affect me in the least the post said it
was evil and demonic
which is a real buzzword there are
people who are too far right that when
somebody says somebody is
trans that they think well that's the
devil in them and it's just like it's
like okay but there's no devil so what
do you don't be so ridiculous anyway
so the
people the woke mob took to the you know
I guess it was Twitter and mostly
Twitter probably and
um and they
basically forced quote unquote the
organization the Blue Jays organization
to tell Anthony bass to apologize for
the thing so he did then
also it's Toronto Jesus is so woke then
he got fired anyway because
it's never good enough for the woke it's
never [__] good enough for the far
left it's never good enough hey
apologize okay sorry oh you're gonna
[__] let this guy still have his job
they want make no mistake the woke
people are the biggest hey don't bully
us but the biggest bullies this is just
they are not happy until you end your
life this is just the truth
this is the only Power they have and it
works when it comes to corporations case
in point Toronto Blue Jays but um
yeah this guy was a pitcher and
apparently he had like he was like
kind of the best on the team and they
just got rid of them because he posted
something on his private tick tock on
his private uh Instagram not in uniform
I am not saying I agree with Anthony
bass I am not saying I agree with Colin
Kaepernick I'm not saying I disagree
with them what I am saying is
if you
are somebody who wants to advocate for
free speech It's gotta be all of it
it's got to be all of it and guess what
that's gonna [__] suck sometimes for
you because people are gonna say [__]
you don't agree with do I think that
trans people have the devil in them no I
don't okay
but I guess people are gonna have to say
that and some people are gonna have jobs
that say that and then when they say
that you got to just go like this wow
that person it sucks they're crazy
but because of that he can't throw a
ball
do with anything
it is such a crazy [__] time we live
in and now
uh I walk around just to spite everyone
I think Anthony best's greatest pitcher
ever lived
he can strikeout anybody
if he was around during Babe Ruth times
Babe Ruth wouldn't have got that many
home runs neither would Mickey Mantle
needed with Roger Maris neither would
Barry Bonds
um I do think though that it's crazy
what he was saying about how uh they
have the devil in them um because they
don't but whatever I'm just free speech
is a kind of a thing I go you know what
I go back and forth on I do believe in
it because I'm a I'm a comedian but also
like
I don't know there's a fine line of what
hate speech is uh I just don't like when
people act like because you uh are some
guy that's just like passively saying
your beliefs that you're you're the
reason why people [__] die because
that's not true silence isn't violence
violence is violence we've said that a
bunch on
on this podcast before and that's that
I also should say that because here's
the other thing too I had a buddy who
got kicked off of Instagram because he
was saying stuff about I don't remember
what it was either Trump or the vaccines
and he was like bro can you help me out
this is [__] up that like they took my
account down and it's free speech and I
don't get to say it now and it's
actually not because it's a business
like There are rules and guidelines you
have to go by about Instagram and it
sucks the rules are guys they have to go
to on YouTube we get flags sometimes for
saying [__] that you have to make sure
you're 18 to sign into the [__] thing
to watch the video and I'm sure we
spread miss all we do is spread
misinformation on this podcast that's
the point of this podcast and
um you know it's well within YouTube's
right to be like this is not what we
want in our business just like it's well
within the right of the Toronto Blue
Jays to be like ah this guy doesn't
believe in what the [__] we believe in
so he's out of the [__] League
however my point still stands what the
[__] does that have to do with throwing
the ball and here's the other thing too
um fans are booing but they don't really
give a [__] that's the thing they're
booming because it's easy to boo they're
still at the [__] game they're still
at the game meaning they still purchase
the ticket so it's not really hurting
their pockets as a matter of fact what
moves hurt your pockets
so
you know I do believe in the fact that
Free Speech does stop when you talk when
you when it comes to a company right
because it has nothing to do with free
speech this is what the company might
stand for or not stand for if you go
against their guidelines then you're out
I get it
um which is what [__] the NFL was
kind of brushing up against with
Kaepernick because they were like well
we can't [__]
you know what I mean
we can't keep
it's bad luck and we're white and he's
black and we're all a bunch of old white
guys
but I get it all these [__] news
outlets suck [__] huge balls and dick
crazy
[Music]